this week on case studies with the biz
doc it's stripe let's take a look at
what happened with the next two tranches
of funding after that January tranche at
a 1.7 billion dollar valuation
validating them as a member of the
unicorn Club they raised 70 million
dollars general catalysts leading that
and coming along to add to its previous
investment at a three point four billion
dollar valuation which is double the
valuation earlier that year and then
just months later they raised a hundred
million dollars at a four point nine
billion dollar valuation that's a big
number and there's only one word for
that and that is damn that is a huge
increase on valuation in such a short
time it is on Elon Musk rocket to Mars
well they made that money last just shy
of two years and then in November of 16
they raised another hundred and fifty
million dollars at a nine point 1
billion dollar valuation that's almost
good for another dam this time capital G
was part of it capital G is a venture
fund inside Google remember I mentioned
Amex and corporate venture capital well
if you take a look you have capital G
visa and Amex strategic investors were
now in the boat along with traditional
venture investors what's the difference
a strategic investor is usually referred
to as a company not normally in the
financial business but for whom your
product or service is strategic to their
vision for the future in other words
venture capital investors are providing
venture funding startup funding in
tranches to startups to grow forward for
a financial return when you get Amex and
Visa and Google involved there's a
financial return as well because they're
carefully managing their CVC fund
corporate venture capital fund I
mentioned a minute ago but they're also
looking for strategic value to be
brought to them in services that they
can get a hold of and make their own
product better that's the difference
between a strategic investor and a
venture investor and strategic investors
come along usually later and can often
be a key propellant going to the future
because they could be a customer they
can also be an early date with someone
who's going to be a buyer and write a
check for the whole company later on so
that's the history how they amassed some
tremendous venture capital partners and
some great strategic partners now if
they're head-to-head with PayPal Tom why
do you think that they were successful
wouldn't PayPal be the existing choice
and just squash all competitors well you
might think that but it's not as easy as
that
there's a lot of ways that a fast
follower can improve what a fast
follower is nothing more than a second
player in the market who's keeping an
eye on the leader and doing everything
the leader does but also adding things
to it and enhancing the product in other
words if you watch PayPal go through and
you see things that were issues for
PayPal maybe data leakage fraud and
things like that and you say aha if I
build something similar to them I better
address those issues very successfully
so I can say well I'm better than PayPal
because of these things that have just
happened well and being a fast follower
is similar to drafting and racing come
up behind the other person let them push
the air out of the way and pass them
when you get the opportunity it's very
much like that in business and that's
what a fast follower is